her name is Therese guy living a home
for disturbed children after the war
there's the thread and reddit last night
just about chilling pictures most of
them are kind of like your classic
historical pictures like here's somebody
just before they died or that kind of
stuff but there's this one which is just
of a girl who grew up in a Nazi
concentration camp here's got a bit of a
funky expression it's not that crazy of
a picture then somebody just they took
half her face and mirrored it and it's
really disturbing
she's like a demon face so creepy I
can't look at her for too long Wow looks
like she's 40 year old coal miner okay
yeah [ __ ] I wonder what your face would
look like they're probably totally
normal probably slightly more handsome
come on months ago they released version
three of octane and with that came this
volumetric rendering engine I've used
octane on all kinds of projects from
nerf Team Fortress video in that little
transforming nerf gun a smallest Empire
all like the towns of stuff Mario skate
classic and that's always been for like
hard objects stuff that is concrete
tactile but with version 3 we can now
render smoke and fire why is that
important to get a good high quality
render of smoke with proper light multi
scattering going through it and all that
stuff it takes a long time to render
however with octane doesn't take as long
anymore I stress test the hell out of it
I put these three little glowing orbs
inside of it it lights up the smoke
around it like you actually would in
real life if you're to put a flashlight
through smoke you would get a bit of a
light trail the smoke itself would blow
even though this is like an abstract
sort of non realistic thing it looks
real because the lighting matches it's
tracked to the shot well shadows look
pretty good and more than that the smoke
is interacting with the light in a
realistic way the PayPal Fiasco is over
a letter that says we're unable to
verify the account information because
the biz
listed as the business itself and I
can't just cancel the accounting changes
because there's a cool money in there
that I can't pull out something in your
company letterhead submitted so much
documentation at this point that the
amount of storage that I'm allowed to
upload is full now I'm calling them back
it actually can worked compliance
finally changed the name to my name
stead of the business name ba blah blah
April 12th
to August 12th you don't use PayPal
don't start for the simulation of the
smoke itself we used a program called
fume effects game effects for works with
octane 3 game FX 3 does not work with
octane 3 so that's why we upgraded the
way octane works is that it renders the
final image all is one final super high
quality immediately but it's really
noisy it's really fuzzy and it's like
that for a little while the longer you
let it render the less fuzzy it gets so
when it comes time to render time he
basically just decide how much fuzz do
you want in your shot so this whole shot
it's 181 frames now this does not have
the lights in it the orbs are still
there they're still colored but they're
not glowing the reason why this took
half an hour and the one with the lights
took 65 hours because the smoke there's
so many different interactions with the
light takes significantly longer to
calculate all the different rays and
light passes through the smoke itself to
get it to properly glow which was great
for us because we learned to not do that
we can do it if we really need to we did
we just we just understand that it'll
take a while fortunately for the video
we're doing right now
we don't need any of those lights we're
just doing literally white light smoke
you can leave the final render pretty
fuzzy and just use denoise or you can
either use red giant a noise or or meet
video denoiser they all work great Gabe
just gave me this really cool surprise
do this so this way Carmichael doesn't
have to keep flashing on screen all the
time
now this isn't in the store currently
but if you guys want to see this in the
store you can bombard the Twitter
account for a quarter digital tell them
that you want to see these shirts in the
store I think it's pretty cool
Gabe you're the best huge shout out to
Gabe's wife who made this her company's
indigo prints apparently Peters gone
I've tried calling him a bunch of times
it doesn't pick up my phone calls
anymore I'm concerned actually so Peter
if you're watching this please you know
send me a direct message I'd love to
hear from you no one will tell me where
you plan
you